wolfenstein the old blood reunites BJ
blaskowitz with the setting that made
him famous castle wolfenstein itself hi
there this is Chris waters standing in
for reviewer Jeremy signor the first
part of this standalone DLC involves
infiltrating the castle in order to find
the location general deaths heads evil
Nazi base BJ is very much in his element
in the world war 2 setting compared to
the alternative history 1960s of the new
order and though there's still advanced
technology it's more in line with what
you'd expect from pulp Nazi super
science for the era firing guns feels
both effortless and flexible and most
weapons can be dual wielded the old
blood absent flows as it constantly
changes up each encounters focus
creating an excellent sense of pacing
action-packed shooting sequences in open
cover Laden levels alternate with more
freeform and surprisingly excellent
stealth sections that don't object to
you taking a more direct approach
there are even portions where you're
encouraged to run rather than fight
there's also some seriously great enemy
AI they'll flank you and take cover
keeping you on your toes yet they aren't
so smart that you can't outmaneuver them
pretty much everything about the way the
old blood plays exemplifies first-person
shooter design in 2015 and is just plain
fun to bj's local contact kessler is a
stark contrast to the burly protagonist
his weapon of choice being leaflets
rather than guns
he's also acutely empathetic of human
life in one memorable exchange he
implores BJ to avoid killing as many
people as he can which BJ then willfully
misinterprets to me that he should kill
as many Nazis as we can we also get a
glimpse of some character among the
enemy combatants albeit only through
memos and a scene where you walk through
a bar crowded with Nazi soldiers even
Helga von shop's the antagonist of the
game is granted some character
development in her lifelong fascination
with adventure and her potentially royal
lineage she also likes wine like a lot
even so BJ still sees his enemies as the
same flat characters he sees in his
Wolfenstein 3d fever dreams good for
only one thing killing the game's
mechanics almost never encourage you to
leave any Nazis alive the old blood is a
blunt muscular bare-chested romp through
levels full of deadly moving targets
even during it's subtle moments and
there's nothing wrong with that but it
fumbles when it attempts to introduce
gray areas into the game whether it's
Kessler's empathy for his oppressors or
the supplementary notes you find
scattered around the old blood seems to
have something to say about the
evolution of games but it never quite
arrives at a solid point
the sledgehammer that is BJ's philosophy
always wins out stranding the gray areas
in a game that clearly won't give them
the time of day the second half of the
old blood changes up enemy types by
replacing Nazis the default enemy type
of the old ERA with zombies it's a nice
change of pace from the terse shooting
areas that came before but they kind of
feel like a downgrade turning a
mechanically smart action game into a
brain-dead one don't get me wrong mowing
down zombies with a sawed-off shotgun
never really gets old per se but the
waves and waves of corpses pouring at
you can't help but feel disappointing
after you've experienced the smart
design of our
one still it's clear that machinegames
understands the nuance that can be
evoked in the medium and the old blood
certainly displays intelligent action
FPS design that's fun and effortless to
play just don't expect the deep
examination the game hints at to go
anywhere hear the gloriously dumb yet
smartly designed reins progress can wait
long live the old blood